The Joe Rogan Experience when it comes
down to like life or death stuff that's
where
you know you're a very determined person
just in the way you live your life it's
cam very determined person right so
that's how you get to where you get to
it's the first ingredient in this whole
control factor is having enough
determination to do that and like you
have a why you you have a why as to why
you're doing this my why was I was
scared to death man in the sniper world
I was like man I hope it doesn't go bad
I'm like that can't be the mindset
but it is the mindset of most cops
because they don't have a why
you know if a cop's never been in a
gunfight or a shooting
their why is artificial
right and that's it's scary the first
time that you that you do that you know
having that why and seeing like
I was in an HR where I you know I had to
use lethal force on a person that was I
had to put around this far from another
human being's face right and it was
that's my why so when I do training on
the team it's like you guys don't
understand when you're when you see when
you're looking through your optic at a
reticle and there's somebody's face on
the edge of the I mean their face is
fully in your scope
and the reticles right on the edge right
and you have to put the round past their
head that's your why right so that's
your y for all this tactical training
that you do but if you've never been
there and done that you have to learn
how to manufacture determination
right can you imagine what failure would
be in that situation well tell the story
if you don't mind the the story you told
me about the guy who was mapped out yeah
so got a SWAT call out of uh of a
hostage rescue there's a an unarmed
barricaded subject for the hostage and
you never know that's all the
information you get on the call out
right so we go there
um I get there and it was weird because
on the brief I walked up to the house
and the the SWAT Commander briefed me at
the at the head of the garage there and
it was light colored concrete
it's dark
you know we didn't have a bunch of
lights on because the operation is
active in that house right there but the
room was in kind of the back of the
house and I I remember he's talking to
me tell me the situation and I'm looking
on the ground and I'm like what is all
that stuff on the ground right and I'm
looking at these dark patches on the
ground so I turn my flashlight on and
it's blood there's blood all over the
place on this on the walkway down from
the garage
I'm like what is up with that and he's
like well this guy stabbed his cousin
and then took his own daughter hostage
user is a human shield with a knife to
her
so that's how SWAT got called and all
this stuff so I get there
and I gotta be I'm up on a ladder over a
wood fence and we're about I'm only like
15 yards from the from the window but we
can't see anything in the window
and the negotiators on the phone with
this guy and he's not really making a
lot of sense he wants to talk to his
girlfriend blah blah blah he's got his
daughter in there with him and we can
hear her through the wall right we can
hear her sometimes she's screaming
sometimes she's crying sometimes she's
laughing so we don't know what is going
on in there right and it go this goes on
for the negotiators are on the phone
with him for a while
and then finally the decisions made like
we have to get in there because it's
starting to go south in negotiations
and we lost columns with the guy and
you're worried he's going to stab his
daughter yeah well we don't I mean he's
already done that to his cousin right I
mean stabbed him in the face and legs
and arms Big K Bar knife it was
it's not a good situation so yeah and
he's already used her as a human shield
right when the when the cops what
happened is there was a big fight went
on the cops got in got everybody out
then they realized the daughter was
hiding behind a couch so they go back
and they restack up they go back in now
he's got the daughter around the waist
using her as a human shield knife to her
and he kicks the door shut on a bedroom
that's what starts the SWAT call out
so
we're I'm looking in this window it's
got blinds on it you know negotiations
are going south we lose columns with the
guy so finally we're like we got to get
comms with this dude so we're gonna put
a throw phone in so we put a throw phone
a throw phone's like a it's like a box
it's got a phone in it so you can the
negotiators can talk the dude
and so we put that in there my buddy
rips the blinds out we rip the blinds
out there's the dude again I can't see
him because I'm I can only see like half
the room and he's on the right he's in
the right corner of the room and I'm
over over this fence
and
the window guys are yelling at him to
drop the girl drop the knife you know
get him all the commands and he's kind
of working his way along the wall he's
got her around the waist so he would
hold her up up above you know so they
can't get a shot and so he's moving his
way across the wall and then he moves
his way across this wall and ends up in
this corner
sits down and pulls her up over the top
of him
and so the windows on the same wall as
this corner and I can't see any of this
stuff I'm the sniper team leader so
I work my way around and I get to this
gate and like they called fire priority
to the window team and I'm like I'm on
the wrong team right
because he's got there's like six dudes
at the window and nobody's shooting I'm
like why in the f are these guys not
shooting because I couldn't see what
they saw but it's just what's going
through my head
so I
I get off the ladder I run to this gate
and I'm it's weird the stuff you
remember they had this it was like one
of those latch type of locks and it had
a bolt through it with the nut all the
way buried and this bolt was like it
felt like it was this long right so I'm
having to unscrew this freaking bolt
right I'm screwing them it's the finest
threads I've ever felt right so I'm
unscrewing this bolt finally being I get
that I go through the gate I come around
I come up to the window
and
there was another officer that was had
his basically his face planted against
the window so that he could you know
could just barely see through this
sliver because it was on the same wall
and uh so
and he wasn't shooting and I'm like why
are you not shooting and so we actually
ended up having to remove him off the
ladder because he I don't know what he
was thinking he wasn't hearing us we
were giving him commands to get off the
ladder so I could get up there and
evaluate the situation
I'm shooting a my sniper rifles at uh it
was a gas operated 308 and lowest power
on the scope was four and a half
and I've told I told the admin years ago
I'm like I need lower power because it's
going to be close probably
when it when it does happen and sure
enough it was so I get up on this ladder
and I put my face against the against
the wall and I can just see through the
sliver I can see
him sitting and I can see her on you
know sitting in his lap basically and
he's got his arm around her
and so and the team keeps giving them
commands and I'm looking at this shot
and I'm evaluating what's going on and
I'm thinking to myself
I'm gonna have to shoot him left-handed
and I'm thinking lowest power is four
and a half so I do an optic check on the
wall I'm like heading into work
so I'm thinking to myself I'm gonna have
to shoot him with my pistol when you say
optic check it's because it's moving too
much no because yeah too much
magnification so there was a picture
something on the wall so I I brought my
my rifle up and looked at him like that
ain't gonna work it was just blurry it's
four and a half power the shots only 11
feet
like 12 feet 11 feet so
I uh
so I'm like this isn't I don't have the
right tool so I'm thinking I'm gonna
have to shoot my handgun
and then I'm thinking I always preach
handguns suck for killing stuff right so
that's why I always tell my guys
handguns suck for killing stuff we don't
use handguns if we don't have to but I'm
thinking I got the wrong tool
what am I going to do so I'm thinking
wait a minute stupid there's six guys
standing at the window that have the
right tool right because they all have
their assault rifles
and uh
so
I the first guy and it just happened to
be the guy that we pulled off the ladder
I'm like give me a rifle he's like what
he'll give me a rifle it's we we swap
rifles and he says HK 416 and the reason
he said that was because on HK 416 if
you flip the safety twice you go to full
auto
right so don't want to do that right and
a Precision environment right so I'm
like Roger that and so I got up and the
window's broken at this point
so when you step up to the window you're
literally walking on broken glass okay
so I step up pop that the glass all pops
underneath my feet
and I push the rifle I gotta shoot
left-handed right so I push the rifle in
and I come around the corner now the
rifle butt is in my bicep with somebody
else's Rifle right but I know this rifle
is zeroed because it has to be zeroed
because to get through my qualification
a month earlier it had to be zeroed
right so I knew that things were good
but I also knew that you got to aim two
and a half inches higher than where you
want to hit because that's a mechanical
offset right difference between bore
height and side height two and a half
inches
so I pushed the rifle in the window and
I come around the corner and I look and
the little girls looking right at me
right because all the broken glass so
she's looking right at me and I I bring
the reticle up and it's full pop
brightness right I can't see anything
because it's he had it set for a white
light shot so when you when you turn
your super bright flashlight on on your
rifle it will it will blare out your
reticle so you got to have your reticle
turned way up well he had it set for a
white light shot but I wasn't going to
do a white light shot so I I looked I'm
like oh no so just like you're thinking
your your thing didn't turn on when
you're looking at this nil guy I'm
looking at this red Sun in a dimly lit
room
and I'm like this ain't gonna work so I
pulled the rifle back out of the window
and now I got to work on the buttons on
this site well this isn't my rifle right
so now I gotta find the button that dims
the dims the Red Dot so I'm messing
around with this thing and the whole
team is outside and they're watching
this right because they're going to go
on my shot now this dude had the had the
door barricaded with a TV and a TV stand
all that stuff so they're gonna have to
hit the door hard but they were going to
get a running start at it but I moved
them out because they were right on the
other side of the door but I didn't know
if my round was going to go through the
wall or not so I moved them out
so we got them out so they're all
watching this show basically of me
on this optic
and they're thinking what are you doing
Turner right and I'm thinking I'm like
should I just got to get this thing
turned down right so I'll mess with the
buttons and I finally get to the to the
right one so I'm like okay good
so
I go back up to the window
you know glass breaks again pop pop
underneath my feet I Come Around the
Corner does this guy know you there
I don't know because he was I mean who
knows what kind of mental state he was
in and I was trying not to be too that's
why I didn't turn on any lights or
anything
so I Come Around the Corner again and I
look in there I'm like okay I got the
right brightness but it's too close
right like her head was like an inch
because what I'm looking at is this so
like this is the back of her head I'm
looking at his eyeball oh so I got like
an inch
I'm like not too close
and remember that
almost so this was on this was in
December a year earlier it was 364 days
after I made that decision in that tree
stand
when I mapped things right so now
between 14 December of 14 and December
of 15 now I'm I have control of what's
going on and I made that vow right long
ago that I'm not going to shoot an
uncontrolled shot
so I come around the corner
and I'm looking and she's of course
looking at me and it's close I'm like
nah I'm gonna do that so I'm waiting
and then he moves his head back right
I'm like okay two and a half inches of
mechanical offset but his hit his head
his face is all covered in hair like
this giant mop of hair so I couldn't see
the geography of his face at all like
I'm going I want to put it in his
eyeball but I don't
I can't see it right so I'm just going
by the curvature of his of his forehead
I know I gotta aim two and a half inches
over that
so I put it up there
safety's off fingers on the trigger it's
a two-stage trigger so I took the first
stage out here I go I remember saying
that and then when I'm when I'm working
on rifle stuff it's it's kind of an
audible exhale so right so I can that's
my that's my concentration guidance
so I put it two and a half inches over
where I wanted to hit safety's off take
the stage out of the trigger here I go
and he moves his head back right boonk
and he pops it back against the back of
her head
and it's funny the stuff you remember
because I remember his hair swishing
right and he's so now he's back and it's
too close again so I'm like I'm waiting
he moves his head back again
so he moves his head back again now I've
got better you know it's faster for me
to aim where I need to aim so I put it
where I need to stages out here I go and
the shot broke and the rest is history
so
it but worst case scenario in terms of
tension in terms of consequences
knife to this girl I mean it's just the
whole that was the culmination of
everything
that was the start of shot IQ
because now I'm like this is no
right this is how to concentrate in high
stress events right so and it was cool
because I had I had lots of high-level
military operators that I was able to
bounce ideas off of like because I'm not
getting in gunfights every day so I go
hey man is this real or is this not real
like yeah how'd you figure that out I'm
like I don't know I'm just a dumb cop
man just just thinking you know and so I
was able to bounce things off of people
that were actually that had been there
and done that and that's
you know when you're looking for solving
a problem
you have to find those people that have
solved it before
but it's so rare to find somebody that
solved it before and blueprinted how
they did it you know that's what's rare
yeah in the instructions and just in
life in general you know there's lots of
mentors out there that have been there
and done that in whatever field you're
looking for but did they blueprint it